يعني غريب هذا بعض السياسيين اظن هودي
لا اريد ان اوصف احدا ولكن نحن نسجل
الحوار في هذا القصر الان هذا كله قصائد
الاصل
يعني الهندسه الخطوط الانحناءات الزخرفه
وفي نفس الوقت لا يدركون شيئا اساسيا كيف
يمكن ان نسمح في بلداننا بتكوين اجيال من
المتعلمين والجامعيين والمهندسين دون ان
نفرض في هذه المناهج كلها
نظاما تربويا
يجعل الطلبه يقراون الادب والفلسفه في كل
انواع واسلاك التعليم هناك دراسه مهمه
كتير حول العمليات الارهابيه والذين قاموا
بها وهيئوا اليها هم كلهم معظم مختصين
بالكمبيوتر بالعالم الرقمي
وبالهندسه وبالاشياء ليس لها علاقه
بالعلوم الانسانيه ولا واحد قاري فلس في
او درس علم اجتماع او درس ادب او شيء
اضافي للنصوص التراثيه التي يعني يختارون
منها ما يساهم على التفجير وانت لو سالتها
هؤلاء هل قراوا في حياتهم
ديوان شعريا او روايه فانهم
سيجيبون طبعا بلا لذلك لابد من يعني من
التعويل والانتباه على تطعيم المناهج مش
تطعيمها على جعل المناهج متوازنه متوازن
ثانيا متوازنه ما الفائده من تكوين مهندس
وطبيب اذا كان هذا المهندس الطبيب لا لا
توجد بداخله ايه بذور من الوجدان المشترك
وهو الخيال المشترك مشتركه